boulangerie café épicerie de nombreuses
communes rurales voient leurs commerces
fermés mais ce n'est pas une fatalité
il sait à dans les places on a fait le
pari de maintenir ces commerces en
décembre 2015 nous avions rencontré un
jeune couple
delphine et raphaël venait alors de
reprendre la boulangerie du village
fermée depuis plus de deux ans depuis un
mois l'odeur du pain chaud embaument à
nouveau cette boulangerie un bonheur
retrouvé grâce à raphaël boulanger de
formation et delphine son épouse ce
couple venu du doubs n'a pas hésité à
reprendre ce commerce de proximité
[Musique]
bonjour rappel bonjour monsieur chanter
jeu complet et delphine bonjour alors
dites moi comment ça se passe pour vous
pour le moment ça se passe super bien
aucun souci nous avons bien progressé on
va dire on travaille beaucoup et vous
delphine il ya quelques temps donc trois
ans comme si on s'était vus vous étiez
poser la question de reprendre ou pas
votre activité d'autres doutent
maintenant je pense pas parce qu'en fait
ça me plaît énormément
puis bon il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
travail donc c'est une affaire qui roule
on peut dire c'est à dire que on
progresse ça va tout doucement et on
espère que ça ira de mieux en mieux pour
l'heure le couple ne se dégage qu'un
seul salaire
mais la petite boulangerie grandi en
trois ans la production a tout
simplement triplé et les clients eux
sont ravis
vous venez un tous les jours vers cette
horde yann formidable on le dirait perçu
c'est rock celles accueillant pour les
aider dans cette aventure la communauté
de communes propriétaire des locaux
investis 60000 euros pour réaliser des
travaux
cette boulangerie une bouffée d'oxygène
pour les 350 habitants du village est un
pari gagnant pour la mairie ici les élus
ne regrette pas les 20000 euros investis
notre boulangerie avait été fermée
vraiment deux ans qu'on a retrouvé des
porteurs de projets on a participé au
financement pour l'achat du premier four
la commune qui a participé également
énormément d'ailleurs la communauté de
communes est-ce que ça en valait le coup
bien sûr que ça valait le coup site et
surtout une attente de la part de la
population dans les classes et de la
population aux alentours
à dans les classes on n'en est pas à son
coup d'essai en 2001 la commune avait
racheté puis rénové les murs de
l'épicerie depuis deux ans le fonds de
commerce appartient une jeune femme du
pays
[Musique]
chez mélodie on trouve de tout
alimentation jeu tabac presse
mais quand on est à la campagne les
relations avec les fournisseurs sont
parfois compliqué notre dépositaire de
dijon a décidé de nous livrer là presque
une journée sur deux pour des problèmes
de rentabilité ce qui est une vraie
difficulté dans une zone très rurale
comme la nôtre où malgré tout il ya
quand même des habitants à l'année qui
prenaient leur journal tous les jours
pas de quoi décourager mélodies depuis
son arrivée les clients sont au rendez
vous les gens jouent beaucoup de jeu on
a beaucoup de chance c'est pas le cas
forcément partout j'essaye de leur
proposer un maximum de choses je suis
ouvert toute l'année et j'ai cette
chance de vivre aussi bien l'été que
l'hiver même si un petit peu moins de
monde l'hiver c'est une activité sur
laquelle j'arrive à vivre bien je suis
très satisfaite
l'arrivée de ces nouveaux commerçants a
fait son petit effet hautmont vue-là le
café historique du village
le patron voit cette nouvelle génération
d'un bon oeil
alors vous jean pierre vous êtes là
depuis un petit moment je crois oui 26
ans
qu'est ce que ça représente un café dans
un village comme nouveau jim jonsin
portant oui oui très important de se
sécher un lieu de rencontre qu'est ce
que vous pensez de cette renaissance un
peu d'écho merci c'est très bien pour un
petit village que nous sommes au moins
les gens ils ont quand même un
multiservices et une boulangerie sur
place you et vous là donc on voit ça a
vraiment emmené dans un petit bar de
campagne comment on s'en sort ou
quotidien financièrement j'entends on a
quand même faible à l'hiver on alléger
les chasseurs j'ai pas mal de trucs et
les ramasseurs de champignons voyez tout
ça et me l'étais il ya des marcheurs il
ya des vacanciers
une passage ecoutez jean clair je
remercie qui ont maintenant on va aller
voir une de vos collègues et amis donc à
l'auberge ensoleillé mais recèle donc
bonne journée merci au revoir dans le
morvan l'auberge ensoleillé est une
véritable institution depuis 1976 daniel
blandin est à la tête de cette
entreprise de sept salariés et pour elle
c'est sur le village connaît un nouveau
souffle
moi je serais très content le petit
boulanger l'épicière ça c'est bien ça
amène du monde déjà et puis jamais de la
vie
ce qui met beaucoup de vie c'est le
boulanger le commerce en milieu rural
vous globalement aussi croyances ça peut
revivre
c'est ce qu'on dit que les gens est
incertaine reviendrait à la campagne ce
qui nous manque c'est quelques usines
vous voyez tout c'est le travail pour le
travail
[Musique]